welcome back to the extra yard I'm
Krista Stefano this is Yanis Papas we
are the history hyenas and we are both
transgender Eskimos that's what we are
today and that's just today and that's
okay and you can laugh at that and I and
I understand that but that's what we
identify as today there's nothing that
you can really say against that cuz
right now I'm feeling like a transgender
Eskimo I want to tuck my dick back and
put a klondike up my ass and that's what
he wants to do and you guys laughing at
us that's uh you know I don't know if
you're doing that to punch down or punch
up now I'm laughing with you okay don't
punch down cuz I make no mistake we have
on a couple of cute sweaters we do yeah
and you guys are kind of matching to
this sounds more like you know knitted
it looks like someone's grandma made it
this yeah it's like you bought a j.crew
I thought it's Banana Republic 10% off
yeah we look like backup dancers for a
rapper so remember those head matching
outfits they did you guys are look like
a like a Christmas card and you guys are
matching Matthew to both the black every
time we do a podcast together we look
like versions of ourselves I'm going on
I just posted on the Santa got a studio
story that I'm convinced
Yanis is my biological father it looks
like I'm 30 so you know what I had to
have you at yeah I would have been I
wouldn't had come in my dick yet but 14
I was when I was coming in 14 yeah no I
don't think I don't think I could come
to about 15 wait that's late that's not
normal it's a normal nope yeah that's a
late developing yeah I don't I think 14
I was doing that you know like oh you
know you're coming at 14 yeah yeah
absolutely
I was yeah that's nice 14 yeah I ate
mine was 18 you kids these days we were
Scarlett sex with black nice hot half
black half Jamaican half Italian girl
yeah yeah no they're the best yeah I
remember we had sex and I swear she came
to my house and she had on a do-rag
I'm not lying not you find on a do-rag
and she loved playing basketball and and
she was hot she a guy she'd been a guy
and we had sex she asked if my mom was
home and I said no and then she I swear
she asked me to get her some apple juice
I guess that's what turned her on yeah
and then we had sex and I got like three
or four pumps and it was bad man like it
was really really bad
oh it was it was a quick thing where she
had already had sex so I was already
like really
care about that and my emotions tip I
remember I went in the bathroom I
started like tearing up I had a lot of
Catholic guilt I felt like I
disrespected my mother yeah and and then
and then I remember we hung out for like
another two times and then it was over
and I keep the do-rag on during the
shellac she kept the do-rag on during
the during sex and she what's bronze so
you couldn't pull her hair you just have
to put your hand on her head
ya know it's like [ __ ] Kenny Smith and
I love and basketball of a basketball
and I'll never forget I remember like
for background noise I put on a spent
aura when nature calls VHS and my room
you know when you're having sex though
and there is something on the TV and you
kind of chuckle at it and it's kind of
awkward for a second yeah but I'm like
I'm actually listening to the TV while
I'm having sex right yeah yeah I'm also
gotten head and my fiance is like watch
TV while she does it yeah and a part of
me feels a certain way about it but then
I'm just like that's alright that's the
[ __ ] what uh what's that [ __ ]
stupid show what Downton Abbey I have
seen it's brown it's old its old white
women talking about being rich yeah oh
that's real relation sex if you're like
watching TV while you're doing it yeah I
don't think I've done this a million
times we put friends on in the
background I used to take it so
personally that's not good enough for
you
you don't like this I'm just like you
know what yeah I understand it's not a
karaoke microphone which they're
probably not great to begin with this be
honest and I just got over chlamydia oh
nice hey guys yeah I'm all the all the
dick talk brought up your committee yes
it's it's good I'm clear but I've been
celibate so you're a boy is that so
you're admitted publicly that why yeah
first-first Bell Oh
first of all committee sec second but I
got the six years ago I got it and then
we just by the way amazing that he only
got it twice yeah I thought you said
chlamydia was amazing I was we had Jeff
die on our podcast a great Jeff done
shot him out and he told her she has
chlamydia like four or five times and
it's just wild
sludge that he puts up numbers I got it
zero times
yeah I want to go on record to say that
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go 0-2 yes
that's zero but that's like hosting SNL
like seven times yeah committee of that
yeah your alleged arrest you guys when
you do it once when you get it once it's
like okay kind of kind of whatever when
you get it six times like this well
here's the thing you guys may have had
it but your immune system killed it I
have a little weak baby [ __ ] immune
system that can't kill it yeah your
immune systems a little [ __ ] it's a
little bit a little [ __ ] - Peck that
little [ __ ] yes sick all the time you
look like a strong kid but the thing is
your immune systems a little partners
[Laughter]
that's a great way to describe your
immune system it's a little bit it's a
little [ __ ] and it's a great way to
just describe you as a person yeah
little bit I'm a little bit I want to
get on something though because yeah we
were on their podcast history hyenas you
guys go check that out on YouTube but
cause you're flexing your biceps and I'm
going point you're gonna get kissed on
the mouth yeah I told you let someone
kiss you on the lips and now that I'm
celibate for a month and I'm chlamydia
free I'm a little backed up and I got
some juice in my balls and they could
get on your nipples real quick well
here's the thing that's what I want to
talk about because I found out on the
podcast that apparently you're only
shooting gigantic lows and you can't you
can't come like two days in a row you
have a load disorder I shoot ropes yeah
we do it if we do a sequel podcast about
Chrissy's come that's gonna be why I'll
try to skip over everyone - no because
this is something I've never heard
before in my entire life but you know
yeah Chrissy CalPERS my CalPERS clan is
wild
it's the the CalPERS gland is the gland
that makes you glue and my gland is
bigger so I reckon over time I was
shootin more glue I was shooting more
just real quickly in a nutshell I was
shootin more glue but as I'm getting
older I'll shoot less glue but it will
actually make my sex drive more normal
I'll be able to pump more glue out I'll
be able to have sex more time this for
you
yeah and and and get and get my glue gun
will be more active than it has been
when I was younger yeah you're gonna
have a disorder that's a good one to
have
if someone just tuned in I think we're
talking about construction yeah he says
he shoots his glue nice
you got tuned in thinking it's like a
construction how to like podcast I have
no idea but I will say that probably
back in the day well like everyone who's
like is a person like I'm not saying
everyone but like a lot of the people
who like my Facebook page they for some
reason think that I'm dislike crazy like
I don't even know which side left or
right not even sure but like anytime I
say anything like oh you know what we
shouldn't like beat up gay people that's
[ __ ] up it's like oh [ __ ] what did
I beat up that gay dude what is this
[ __ ] or like I put up this thing because
we donated art art patreon in the month
of December to building walls in Africa
and yeah what do you suck a dick name
this podcast Hillary Clinton wait can't
we subsidiary podcast Sean Terry
patrimony that was a lot afford a couple
firefighters what are the names again
I'm patch Maroni is my friend Sean
carrier and we're five fighters I that's
been 4865 days since 9/11 for Isis well
actually yeah we're from this area
around here just we're from somewhere
here yeah and and we will save you from
a burning building as long as we don't
see any pro-hillary signs up in Unipart
if you got to take a ferry or a bridge
bridge to get into whatever city you
live in that's us that's what we live
for
yeah from out there we do boats and we
pay tolls and bridges yeah absolutely
and we vote to the right everything's to
the right yeah Merry Christmas I don't
say do any of [ __ ] Happy Hanukkah I
mean you know it's like I know what
these people doing but ya know we'll
save you
alright we're back Chris is back thank
God you guys are back because I wanted
to talk about your podcast a little bit
so history hyenas mm-hmm it's a it's a
podcast that's [ __ ] this mess that we
have over here but it also is kind of
founded in this history
sort of thing where did that come from
well the truth of the situation is this
we're both kids for Yannick
really from Brooklyn I'm a kid who was
born in Queens but identifies being from
Brooklyn so we're just two kids from
Brooklyn yeah and we both had black kids
from Brooklyn we but we had to hide the
fact that we loved history so much
because of our Brooklyn roots so when we
found each other because you can't the
thing is like I live in I grew up in
Ridgewood Queens and there's a lot of
this it's one of the biggest designated
historical areas in the whole country
Trump that vote Trump and all the signs
are brown they're not green all the
street signs are Brandon when you have a
brown street sign in New York that
designates a historical block now I
couldn't be open about the fact that I
knew that to the Maclaurin he brought
any likes guys one of them was in jail
because the McCarney brothers if I would
have said hey did you guys know that the
brown street signs designate historical
block they would have removed the sign
and stuck it up my ass I can't I can't
do that so history was gay history was
gay history our knowledge in my
neighborhood is gay also performing
stand-up comedy doing anything if you're
not a cop fireman or garbage man or
construction your full-blown yet they
think no but I my friends support me but
they all like I got a homosexual friend
he times Christmas definitely you've
seen him on girl so so that's how we
found our love of history cuz Yanis
comes from the same thing we're like we
love history we always wanted to like
kind of think about things that happen
in history and relate them to modern day
stuff and so that's how we came up with
it and then Yanis was obsessed with the
animal hyenas so we came up with the
name yeah I love hyenas I love nature
but hyenas I've always it's my favorite
animal just because how wild they are
and then just it just came together to
the first to the first chicks with dicks
yeah they're trance they're
transcutaneous have what they call a
pseudo penis they have a penis that they
give birth out of fake dick it's a fake
dick and not worth a third if you've out
of there they're not a real dick but it
is a pseudo paints a pseudo penis so
that's why in our podcasts we give
somebody every week that our best
patreon member patreon.com slash Bay
Ridge Boys they're our patreon member
that comes up with the best patreon name
we give them the ppw the pseudo penis of
the week
and then there's stages it's prestigious
so what happens is the hyenas give birth
through their pseudo penis and a high
percentage of the time I don't know the
exact number but a high percentage of
the time it actually the baby exhale you
know baby explodes the pseudo penis tick
and kills the month and it's also a
matriarchal driven Society the women are
the top of that society not the men so
we figured as two men who are
identifying as women yeah that we also
we're very close to heinous and their
main weapon of choice like how a lion
you know will go for the jugular or a
Panthers weapon is stealth
hyenas weapon of choice is chaos they
actually create chaos yeah to distract
the prey and then start killing you one
by one and they eat you from the legs
first so most animals will crush the
trachea and eat a dead animal they like
to eat you alive so it's kind of wild
yeah how you know you guys are too wild
trans boys yeah we are absolutely weird
we're chicks with dicks - yeah trans
girls trans girls it's okay mother's
dying from this exploding penis I don't
have a stat 60% of the time according to
the New England Journal of Medicine
that's our podcast where hyenas cuz like
look if you think we're a history
podcast you got another thing coming
yeah we're two comedians who do history
were to Wikipedia [ __ ] yeah it's like
listen we got a manager now and he's a
really makes money he's trying to listen
to our podcast call him the truffle we
call in the truffle pig cuz he's just a
pig that goes out there in little balls
of money like truffles we just want me
to find the little bags and money for us
yeah so we comb the truffle pig and he's
trying to tell us oh you got to have
more of a but this of that of a kind of
you know a structure of the podcast and
we're like no that's not how he knows do
it that's not how we're gonna do it but
I love the way you say hyenas yeah hi
heinous heinous we had you guys in our
podcast yeah and we talked about
Chrissy's come for 40 minutes 40 minutes
yeah yeah Christmas party yeah he
doesn't care or he's a hyena yeah well
and your guys podcast for us and helped
us so much because if your guys rabid
hyena [ __ ] it fanbase that day it was I
think our most watched down and
downloaded episode we've ever done yeah
and we have similar fans like New York
like it was just a lot of girls named
Gina who were like my two favorite
podcast yeah
finally something bigs happening on the
island my worlds are colliding right now
yeah girls love saying [ __ ] like that
and like honestly
oh my god this can't be [ __ ]
happening like yeah like this some
astronomical thing that we're doing here
I like we lived on like some planet yeah
and we came down here and we meshed yeah
made a show when I posted on my
Instagram that we were all together
people would like be they heard they say
it was like the same girl with the same
look just different handles but all like
the same mind they were just right here
for it here for it Oh Chris Danny on its
hip hooray
I just kept writing that if we did a
mash up hot guys like a live podcast I
think like all the outer boroughs would
just be they'll be cleared out again
don't everyone be in the city that
weekend yeah yeah absolutely
we clean up in there chlamydia will come
back I'm getting it again I want to ask
you yeah see I I've I've been fortunate
to have a clean penis but I kind of envy
people who have had STDs I'm gonna tell
you why because they handle it so well
the second time like right like the
first time you get chlamydia you were
probably like oh my god now this time
you're like take a week off actually
it's actually the opposite for me the
first time I got it I was like yeah
whatever the second time because you
know I'm older now I have a kid it was a
little bit like what are you doing you
know your dick my dick stripping at
Disney World
it's like what did you give your dick to
look down and go what are you what are
you doing you're a bad boy have you got
a daughter yeah that behaved and and it
was like the doctor that called me he
was a nice guy the doctor he was just
like any younger guy and he was just
like look he goes you know with the
amount of unprotected sex she told me
you're having out there he said the fact
that you only have chlamydia
he said you has to be a wake-up call
she's a warning he's like I feel like
it's a warning from the universe now
because he's like I just made a call to
somebody similar age similar everything
to you that does not have this good of
news he's got a couple of permanent ones
that are positive he said so you got out
so scot-free take the medicine it'll go
away and then you so I've been actually
celibate now for six weeks and the set
the power of saying no to women I don't
think that means you're celibate though
what do you mean
six weeks is just not that's like being
want to know and be like we're on the
water defeated I've been celibate for
six weeks yeah but I bet you I can make
it I bet you I can make it a while
because I'm addicted now to the power of
just going home and jerking off or just
talking to a girl that I actually liked
and not worrying about having sex with
her like just being like oh you wanted
you actually want to go get dinner
because he used to be
just come over do you want to what let's
get pizza and hang out by me do you want
to just come over yeah that what that
was my that's what my life was hell to
get creative
not even creative now like I actually
prefer to get to know a woman I'd
actually prefer that so what has made
you better purse
chlamydia slay a better person committee
has made me realize that to become
friendly with my present chlamydia made
me start listening to Eckart Tolle who's
a great spiritual leader so thank you
yeah bye dick drift right on to a
spiritual healing you're you're very
vulnerable right now to be like scooped
up and swooped up by a cult by cult if
someone comes along with any charisma
and who's looking like as that
leadership wallet he's got it Chris is
gonna follow you I'm their new tattoo I
feel like anything you'll ever get into
fad was gonna come from some kind of
sexually transmitted disease yes it's
gonna be like dude I'm vegan now it's
like what did you get go vegan yeah I
had chlamydia right you know like if I
made you change your life right right
right right yeah most people have like a
person or like you know mentor like have
you ever did that Sam Adams commercial
you ever see that one they're doing now
but they go who's the person you want to
dedicate to have a beer with and you
have a cheers to right all the comedians
are doing it Tom Segura did oh yeah
yours would be like you know I'd like to
have a beer with who changed my life
chlamydia chlamydia some idiot taught me
to miss penetration of comedo thank you
she was a tiny little bottle with the
committee thank you so much um I really
turned it around I'm also like I condoms
are weird I have this thing like with a
condom it's like when I would have to
put them on my dick would get soft
mm-hmm because I'm focusing on you know
[ __ ] your vagina yeah but and you're
impossible your face guys look like egg
dudes of course you gotta come on you
know maybe yeah I was thinking like when
people say they go suck
I was like yeah coz that's a good time
to just think about that you really want
to be with a guy yeah just don't have a
second to think about what I really want
what we usually I am thinking about that
yeah
but the second I take my mind off my
peepee goes me me soft you know what I
mean yeah yeah and I don't know what
that is but something is just weird
about wearing a condom inside a vagina
it's not an act almost it doesn't count
as sex like like I want to know your sex
number and you could tell me 20 but I'm
gonna say how many of that was
unprotected you'll say - I'll say the
one that you bet sex with two people
yeah because the other 18 you were
having sex with a condom inside of
another person I think I've worn for
condoms in my entire life
right wow you're a kid who likes to go
rowdy you like to go raw Daddy yeah I'm
skinny dip yeah you only use cons oh no
that's not that I'm not gonna say that
I'm just saying like I'm not like you
don't I'm not sleepy right right I
understood I'm smart he stood very high
probably have 11 kids I don't know about
yeah and I wish I did cause I be able to
claim them on my taxes right having a
kid it's great yeah and it's like having
a kid is like Rican half Puerto Rican
yeah so how old is he and how old is you
you could be his dad I could know you're
35 it would have to be he might have
nicely all the connection you guys are
half half Puerto Ricans he had a
character maureesa that only is for the
Puerto Ricans and my daughter is half
Puerto Rican so we all are Puerto Rican
we're four I dated two Puerto Rican his
mother's so Catholic that I think it's
possible that the only reason he hasn't
gotten something worse is because his
mother has prayed to Jesus there's some
voodoo going on I think it might be you
you might invite he's saying you never
use economy never gets I think I think
that I think do you think they're lying
about the stats of the STDs yeah are you
I just think we're just getting lucky I
think people are just lucky like going
honestly I'm gonna be 100% honest with
you yeah your [ __ ] machine yeah so and
and the fact that you don't have any
magic Johnson the fact you don't have
that yeah like that doctor said is a
miracle right now with this information
right are you gonna start strapping up
absolutely I don't believe it
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it better
be careful you're gonna get a talking to
the gym you
I said I got a talking channel no no no
no no I'm gonna do it I'm gonna just
hook it up and say what you said to me
daddy don't [ __ ] say that yes when
you say that it makes me feel like I
can't do it yeah I'll be your condom
sponsor yeah just [ __ ] call me when
you're about to [ __ ] yeah Milton I'm
gonna do up no because I think what
happened was is I started to get that in
that zone where I was like oh whatever I
don't care I'm I'm in my 30s now I don't
[ __ ] care it's like I'll go raw dog I
don't care whatever I'll have another
baby rat disease I'll just deal with it
but then you know when you get older and
you start to get agent a baby I mean
what else do you got a mortgage I mean
you're an adult that's how everybody
goes everyone from the neighborhood's
got it I gotta get it eventually I'll
get to it oh you know why it's called
the history hyenas because this kid he's
he's a high he really is like this wild
human hyena he's [ __ ] wild yeah
there's an ethics backtrack that
explained to people what I'm saying yeah
because then people of my perch life
brother
I don't need those things true and I'm
like I don't know we have pending
lawsuits against our pocket what it is
we're a podcast that's here for a good
time not along yeah we're on the run
we're on the run have you have you guys
ever done like a history of STDs on your
show but that's gonna be the next
episode oh yeah you actually find out
we're gonna get in the first case of the
clap ever came from well there is some
interesting history facts about STDs
like tell how much they played into war
so we did we were doing an episode about
World War two and the Germans right it
was in the Battle of Dunkirk so they had
cornered the Germans had cornered
British and French troops in like a
little corner of France a port city
called Dunkirk and there was a there was
a war there right before they corner
them and Dunkirk for about eight months
cuz a war just stopped that happens a
lot people don't talk about that but
like war machines like they'll just stop
like for eight months we'll just be
camped in a place no nothing from the
enemy where Lanna redoing our battle you
know work and I remember that from like
school like yeah it's like world war two
was from nineteen forty something to
nineteen fifty I'm like wait wait yeah
no one's over there eating camping for
nine years
yeah well Americans it's like I feel
like World War two only starts in the
American
like they entered in fort the end of 41
so 41 to 45 but it was really in 1938 it
started when Hitler was just like I'm
just gonna start taking over
Hillary's just I'm just gonna start
eatin countries next to me that's a got
a buffet table and he was just started
but here's the little advances and I'm
sure we only found one example of it but
I'm sure if we search if we do the
history of STDs which we will do so
thank you for that we're gonna find more
where it's like the the when when they
were having that the part of the war
where they would just stop you know
inevitably like men will be met right so
you're in France so the French and
British troops started getting
prostitutes the British and French
government wanted this they wanted
prostitutes and all that to come in to
the to the camps to keep the morale up
for the soldiers you know whatever so
suck dick in a war zone right where
Germany they do they do and all you want
to do it listen either unbelievable
either you're gonna bang a prostitute
are you gonna bang a guy you're gonna
bang both and that was my grandpa but
but I gotta keep shittin she goes down
in those trenches but Germany Germany
the Nazis were very much like we will
not have any women infiltrating the with
nobody
no women I don't care you gods got a
jerk off whatever we're Nazis this is
not there's no women in this camp so
they were against prostitution so when
they finally came time to invade when
the Germans were invading I mean it's
more to it the French and British we're
also just being the French were being
French and just smoking cigarettes and
not learning the manuals if the tanks
where the Germans had this new Panzer
tank that was rolling over everybody in
the German and the French and the
British had tanks that were kind of as
good but they didn't know how to do the
met because they weren't paying it they
weren't working but the biggest thing
was they were they was rampant chlamydia
gonorrhea syphilis through the French
and British camp from the prostitutes
they were all fighting as sick men where
the Germans were coming in with fresh
dry dish yeah
just coming in at least penises like
yours yeah we miss dosterone built up in
those balls so a lot of people believe
that the STD rates in certain camps in
World War two had an actual impact on
the battles because when they're
fighting with a sickness that ill I mean
strep throat for your dick it's a
problem and we don't feel good it's true
and then also historically French are
known as to be [ __ ] absolutely may be
they just had a bad time with their day
right well right which is another thing
which is will we cover there's two on
the podcast two about how kinda like
misconceptions like they're actually
France actually in the 1930s was the
number one fighting group force in the
world
yeah but it's just bad press it's like
this West Virginia everybody thinks West
Virginia is like or a hick State West
Virginia it's like in the South they get
some of the most they get one of the
highest percentage of students from
those schools that from those high
schools that go to Ivy League colleges
but the smear campaign on West Virginia
started because in the Civil War when
Virginia West Virginia was initially
fighting with the Confederate south and
then Abraham Lincoln was like hey West
Virginia if you come to us we'll just
you will free everybody and everybody
all the slaves will be free and you'll
come with the Union so West Virginia
went and fought with the north they
fought with the north and the south
throughout the course of the Civil War
so the Confederacy was like okay [ __ ]
West Virginia smear campaign you're all
hillbilly you [ __ ] your cousins and blah
blah but none of it's true
it's a smear campaign yeah wild I mean
I'm sure there couple cousins have
absolutely yeah
honestly that's when I you know went on
at any time I'm in the mouth five any
color any common way to mood to have sex
with my cousin we go to West Virginia
that's where we do like it's legal there
yeah it's like going to Vegas a good
marriage yeah yeah the history I he
mysteriously think about a pock I'm
trippin you're gonna feel like you learn
a lot and then you're gonna feel like
you haven't learned a lot the same exact
time yeah they're gonna get a race it's
gonna whatever you're learning you're
never sure if it's true I don't know if
anything he just said is true it is true
to a degree do we do great if you
believe in it yeah it's true but that's
anything in history it's like how do you
how does a history professor telling me
what the facts are how do you really
[ __ ] know I read a story and it's
also the people that want it's the
winner that's why I read this book 1776
about the American Revolutionary War I
read it to ya and what I loved about
that book is he did so much research
from the British point of view he all
that got all David McCullough's the
author's research was from the British
point of view so I really was [ __ ]
with that I'm I feel way overweight so
this isn't this is American ideals is
not you know well what we learn about
like oh Paul Revere and it's none of its
really true yeah other things are true
whenever you read about like a great
in the past like leading his troops in a
battle I always wonder like just with
common sense you going was Alexander the
Great in the front was he really yeah
wouldn't he have died the first battle
yeah that's what happens to the kids
that's right yeah they don't limp from
the front back with a sprained ankle
yeah George Washington wasn't he was in
the back some horse it's just what it is
it's out there I think there's on some
ship imagine though you're in the
[ __ ] war too and your job was just
the plate trumps yeah [ __ ] die yeah
I'm sorry are you going out with a drama
the guy with the food yeah at least if
you got a drum you can hit someone over
the head with a stick but you got a
flute you kind of yeah well what we
learned that you know the Hessians which
was like the german mercenary fighting
force in the Revolutionary War they
talked about this in 1776 they fought
with the British they would come ashore
and start killing American soldiers and
skinning their faces and putting their
putting the American soldiers faces on
there it's like it was [ __ ] Halloween
so I wonder if they saw a guy with a
drum they back oh yeah he's not
they would cut his [ __ ] head off I
always wondered that too and Saving
Private Ryan right when you see the
Hessian sessions was a German mercenary
fighting force mercenaries are like
Britain hired them so this is another
thing about what we learned about just
Germanic people about how vicious
they've been throughout history like
they didn't start with the Nazis
they've always been this way and yes so
like that in Ridgewood they were like
kind of like like the SEAL Team six of
Nazis like but like not ripping people's
face off like SEAL Team six shot Osama
bin Laden and I these guys just like
ripped your [ __ ] out for it as a
necklace
they wore they they didn't they are no
cause the British had a cause to defend
their colonies the Americans had a cause
to gain independence and freedom was
just a kind of a little [ __ ] and I
can explain that if you wanted to but
you don't have to but that's also a
little [ __ ] but so the Hessians were
just hired to kill they're just killing
machines they were hired guns by the
British and they're huge they were all
what they were like two inches taller
than the average man at that time so
that's a big height advantage so they
were five five yeah yeah there were five
seven yeah yeah and so what they would
come they would kill people they would
kill the soldiers you know and then they
would sometimes they would like scalp
them cut their faces off and do kind of
desecrate the bodies because they just
wanted they were
a thirst for blood with the British were
gentlemen fighters like they would kill
you but it played a fluid right play you
know March / March I don't know if
that's what the British say I mean they
promised with the British yeah they
drinking tea out there but the British
were [ __ ] brutal British coming in I
mean if you're in the war you brew yeah
but they go to India and they're like
the yeah they like have a goatee and
then like I can't now murder everyone
yeah King and queens weird stuff it's
weird stuff yeah it's it's like a little
bit like what do you talk what do you
mean what are we doing it they would you
know talking about we made a daughter
says she's the queen of England yeah we
did we did women
yeah alright and we talked about some
wild [ __ ] on the show right [ __ ] like we
she definitely get [ __ ] for but whatever
I'll [ __ ] on your chest I would love
that which was invented by the Germans
yeah - yes yes yes - how much but uh
Germans have bird yeah they are there
come on the show Germans every time Joe
looks out the window and the light hits
his unreleased art he's so handsome I
start to pre-cum a little bit and I
think the chlamydia is back yeah no but
we did this bit on [ __ ] Royal Wedding
the Royal Wedding oh my god and we were
like yeah this is weird like having a
queen it's just weird strange got a
Visser ate all the birds the birds came
after us
really yeah she's a sign of [ __ ]
loyalty in the ball conditioned thinking
[ __ ] so does she actually do out
there they do yeah like the the
Scandinavian countries have them - and
so they all defend them by going you
know what they represent the country
they do a lot of charity work
yeah they go over there and they just
make us look good and they they do some
diplomacy you're going like they're not
real so they're like PR they're a part
PR team for the country but it's kind of
a PR team for the country gives them
something to talk about but they don't
do any they don't make any no look
you're from my old world look I'm Europe
is like television and America's like
the Internet
you guys are doing an old way that's
over like you know that's like a sitcom
guy yeah you're king and queen what do
you [ __ ] 1700s
yeah we got the president's name's
Donald Trump overall but what are you
doing [ __ ]
Kingsman yeah and we elected him he
wasn't born with a [ __ ] silver
sporters mouth he made it himself he was
elected by the people who have health
care forgot to put on do it kings and
queens and healthcare it's like nah guy
guys capitalism let the [ __ ] weak die
in the streets run 2020 the [ __ ] guy
who rose up from he blows it from the
grant from the ground all the way up to
become a [ __ ] man then their cousin
2024 and reshawna slow a small loan of a
million dollars yeah yeah I mean it's
really like old-world [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
I was always so confused by that I'm
like I live in this palace like who's
paying for all this it's the taxpayers
and they they willingly pay they willing
crazy and you want to know why they
could pay and then they're gonna hate
you for this but the truth is like
whenever NATO goes to war whatever and
all those countries are in NATO
we fight for everybody so they don't
have to pay their tax dollars for the
military they're paying them for their
queen is sit around and take pictures
and that's because they have the luxury
of having us fight for them so you know
what goddess is going down that's what
it is they resent like 500,000 troops
they always sound like they send a food
truck and they're like the Netherlands
is part of this world like you know guy
no more king and queen I want I want
some of those hot studs from the
Netherlands to put on some uniforms and
[ __ ] get out there be a [ __ ]
soccer team you have two British back
into those [ __ ] redcoats so I can get
a little [ __ ] job done for my dad
goes to sleep yeah let's get some of
those boys on the field and get your
king and queen back on the bank I love
ya I love that America though it's like
obviously we had the civil war here and
then we've had some domestic attacks but
like any other war we're like nah now
we're not gonna do we never throw
parties we don't want the cleaner well
that's why that's why well that's why I
think that's why I think more than
anything that Jesus Christ himself as an
American kid because he put the Atlantic
Ocean between Europe and the United
States the only reason why we don't have
any wars is cuz we got the oh Sh
and I think Jesus strategically said
that's something to put America dad
because smile a net explain explain yeah
explain a science-y a big way yeah I
think explain how Jesus isn't an
American kid from Brooklyn New York if
you put the Atlantic Ocean on America
and he gave the eight [ __ ] Yanks
Championships and it gave the Yankees
that means Jesus is a [ __ ] kid from
Brooklyn it is
it's not an ocean it's a moat it's
keeping them out let's give it about
yeah it keeps them all out so I know
Jesus is a kid from Brooklyn it's like
you want to attack me you can attack me
I got the proof yeah yeah it's there I
mean it's all there
in the pool yeah it's all there your mom
very Catholic absolutely Briah my dad
died I got a sympathy card from his mom
yeah really yeah yeah Church and little
candle that's how we know my dad is
we're in heaven and the gay part of
heaven specific yeah there's a gay part
Evan my dad liked to paint so he's
definitely that we wanted to go right
your dad sent his dad signed up just
like I can comfortably say I'm not 100%
straight and I know you honest his
father's not a hundred percent straight
and neither is he honest yeah none of us
in this room are a hundred percent right
watch any of my content you know yeah
not a hundred I'm in the high 80s but
I'm not a hundred now no I think the
people that like tell you you're 100
you're like oh you might be more than me
but yeah yeah exactly
do you think gay dudes think about like
I want to just take down a straight dude
tonight is that like a big conversations
with Jews before saying like it's like a
challenge to be like oh that's a
straight guy but I bet I can get him to
turn them out yeah basically I think
they want that more if they can get a
little sense you I've been told
unfortunately by a lot of my gay friends
that they don't get any gay vibes off me
and I'm like I feel like it's brewing
inside but like no you're not gay a
phony or thorny guy where it is I think
we're so openly gay with our content
that the real gay see right through us
say like you're not gay but once those
gay eyes get on us they glance there
wasn't even women are like yours you
know they'll say compliment me and I'm
just like I just talked about sucking
[ __ ] and taking Benadryl 's and stuff
and I'm like we love it I'm a pride
leader apparently dude you did it you
did an Instagram photo and just
underwear you're a you're being jerked
off to by a lot of guys yeah cuz you're
a hardcore bear thank you oh yeah it's a
big he's a big bear cuz he just got
waxed so he's not there right now yes
the big old pile of meat yeah what's the
yeah your bear we're a couple twinks
your beefcake I'm a beef absolute beef
yeah you work out I do work out but I
don't I I'm [ __ ] psycho I'm getting
better at it but like Joe and he takes
his shirt off he's got a nice bod when I
take my shirt off you're like wow I
wasn't expecting that weird but it fits
well in this way
I I look I I think I'm a comfortable
place right I'm okay enclosed I'm not
you know I I have like um what do you
explain me as I look like a guy you look
like the guy who leading role in a
skinemax movie yeah I'm not ripped
I'm not ripped at all but he said to be
honest and now and become good enough to
go to the beach you look like somebody's
dad who's kind of in shape at the beach
yeah yeah you look that's you looks
great 4:45 but I'm strong now and I'm
just I consistently exercise that box
lighter so you got into boxing yeah yeah
I've been boxing a lot so I mean I used
to be like I used to weigh like 255
pounds yeah that's a big boy was wild
like double chin so I don't have that
anymore which is which feels nice and
icky he's got up he's got a big lunch
lady ass yeah I got a mellow thing that
they got a black lady's ass that's what
I was worried about when you guys are
coming in I'm like Chris is gonna come
in here there's a lot of expensive stuff
around oh yeah I'm not gonna think I got
an ll a lunch lady ass but I have no
fumes for whatever reason is I don't
know why no matter what I don't have any
body odor
I always just smell 100% clean and I
have you know he feels that way - yeah
you stunk a little bit far between
I don't wear deodorant at all yeah me
neither and I just never spied enough I
think Germans we just don't have few now
I know I've smoked you a few times you
weren't 100% no yeah yeah yeah I think
it's just you we don't smell to
ourselves
no but you smell no but like you like
you're so you're Nelly God yeah you were
sleeping I put my nose right up in your
ass really and it didn't smell great
yeah isn't nice well maybe I was a
little too close yeah you just did right
by it are you one of those guys is just
lucky enough to have a hairless ass I
have I have almost no body here yeah of
these hairless my legs I don't know here
I'd know where we born [ __ ] Chernobyl
yes Lanterman probably yeah he's a
Sphynx cats oh my god he doesn't have
like no and it's just one it's a very
little facial I'm just kind of sphynx
cat yeah that's huge though mm-hmm it
really is that probably why I don't
smell yeah I think my theories the hair
looks like it stinks yeah what about a
balloon abortion yeah that's why I don't
think guys in the 70s ate [ __ ] cuz
you'd have to get through that minefield
yeah yeah like I am NOT Bush I like a
bush I like top Bush but like not lit
bush do you like eating puss with Bush
though Lynne yeah no I don't know like
looking hair I can lick the hair I don't
mind it I don't really go down I'm girl
I'm going down more now but I wasn't
going on cuz I was constantly getting
sore throats but but now but I I would I
would eat a girl I did have a girl with
the bush recently and I enjoyed it I
enjoyed the bush yeah yeah Oh is she
like if not have no she's a 30-30 have
you tracked the chlamydia back to the
vagina
no no just I don't know yeah that
chlamydia is in the wind yeah I don't
know yeah because also like chlamydia
can just be in your system for a while
oh yeah I was told that joke I hope no
girls you banged their fans at the
basement yard I'm sure they are open you
are yeah Chrissy at some point he just
oh it's always gonna come out it's gonna
it's like you you know secrets we did
for podcasts episodes where we didn't
say anything about this yeah and then he
waited to come on a bigger podcast to
announce that he has chlamydia yeah so
we were keeping it a secret
on our pocket raise like let's go to a
bigger audience so that I can now let it
go yeah but here's the thing with me is
I'm also cwl Chrissy white lies I
couldn't also not have chlamydia none of
it's true
so you if you ask me directly we have a
personal connection I'll tell you the
truth but this is entertainment so I'm
just going with the flow and saying
what's funny I don't you it's all true
but it's also Bible yeah I wanted to say
you had a drip at Disney so the only way
I can get it is if I say you have
chlamydia so maybe I do maybe I don't
know I just listen into the show
yeah you don't know what him you don't
you never know you never know if he's a
girl or a boy you never know what's
going on what's true what's false well
you just don't know you can't you can't
if you're gonna try to get us in trouble
you're not gonna be able to do because
we say so many wild thing yeah I don't
know what to get us it's kinda is
character piece it's character character
I'm friendly with my presence so
whatever my president says that's what
I'll say and you learn that from your
Fuhrer Eckhart Tolle Eckart all unlisted
to his podcast he has with Oprah a nice
and I'm in a good place mentally yeah
yeah
you're a wild kid yeah you want to chain
to the same thing and I love it yeah
yeah yeah with diamonds in one small one
big yeah one small one big and the
brother Jesus haven't talked to Jesus in
ages I love you guys you're making
millions of dollars or whatever you're
making Justin clothes you guys slept in
last yeah yeah I mean he looks like he
just got out of bed and rolled in here
there's no no when I came in with flat
no dude when I came in because I came in
before you he's still at his Morningwood
he's yeah yeah I get started watch
though bones
he was tucking it out a little bit you
know what's up it's gonna know so but
that's what yeah but that but that's the
beauty about about the new world is that
you got I [ __ ] love it
okay and a lot of people hate it but we
love it cuz we're coming yeah could you
see could you imagine if your
grandfather the great mr. Sun Sun Santa
got oh okay then he would he was like
you're at work and you're like yeah I'm
at work you're at work right now yeah
he's like you don't have a suit on you
don't got a [ __ ] yeah I just rolled
out of bed and I'm making a hundred
times the amount of money he did grandpa
it's like I also didn't drink a hundred
beers and punch grandma alright yeah
my grandpa one time I told him I was
sick I was like throwing up all night
like at his house lived in Maine and in
the morning my mother's like she was
like I don't know taking care of me or
something and he walk so he's like
what's the matter and I was like I don't
feel good they're tough for humans back
oh yeah he's a savage did I ever tell
you that story how my grandpa punched
that woman in the snow no wait she
punched her hold on listening all right
so uh domestic policy no Mike my
grandfather was just like an old [ __ ]
abusive man no no no yeah yeah but I was
just supporter weak inside or the this
is the Italians miscellany yeah he came
here really hit the Puerto Rico the
Italians wasn't even his wife right just
a one that I know of you said yeah you
say the time kids just they have a
passion for it Italian kids just like to
discipline their women a little bit
that's just what it is it's just a part
of what it is and I know you can you can
you can get mad at me for saying it I'm
not saying anything that ain't true
I'd like to just give a little
discipline Gina what the [ __ ] is going
on oh my god meatballs and again this
[ __ ] garlic is not [ __ ] sliced the
way my mother did I told you make it
like my mother yeah Italians do have a
very weird sexual connection just watch
The Godfather Part 1 but yeah so it was
we had drunk neighbors I wasn't born yet
but at this time it was just like this
drunk Irish couple like every time you
come home like their family didn't come
here on a boat like three weeks before
right so there they're there and this
woman's outside Angelo you [ __ ]
Italian piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] so my grandpa
was like all right like let me go
outside it's snowing it's like
peacefully snowing right and she's it's
beautiful and she's standing under the
streetlight just hurling racist things
and my grandpa is what my dad told me so
he uh put slippers on he walks across
the street and he sees her yelling at
her yelling at him just [ __ ] going
off and he just slapped the [ __ ] piss
out Wow there you go I just left her in
the snow yeah and I came back in sat
right back that I can do you we're not
out to you but just one better away my
my aunt her husband who's passed away he
somebody robbed my mother on the corner
of our block and they and at the bodega
there was like a pocketbook purse
stealing ring they would steal women's
purses and divvy up the money at the
local bodega that my uncle would go to
and my uncle was there one night
listening to the story he unknown his
sister-in-law had gotten robbed and he
is a psycho and he was listening to what
was going on and he wasn't putting two
and two together he's like oh I think
that's my sister-in-law so he doesn't
say anything but he makes a mental note
and later on that night he gets this guy
nice and drunk brings him back to the
garage in my house where he would do a
lot of welding work ties him up and puts
a blowtorch to his knees and melts the
skin off his kneecaps yeah so and I
wasn't told about that story until years
and years later our families are great
yeah
we just say you know it was the times
yeah yeah it was a time yeah it's like
kneecaps is and it happen when I was
like seven years old I loved how like
there was a man in my garage getting
tortured potentially to death and I'm
just having dunkaroos a jello yeah
that's like a scene in a Quentin
Tarantino movies just a psycho he just
got drunk he's a psycho and it's just
what got us I don't want to get me loose
to discipline his wife to hear that too
and he was Puerto Rican what can you
know sorry I'm sorry about that
no I'm on behalf of all of us yeah yeah
what are you gonna do we let him fly
sometimes Catholics like the discipline
Catholic like its amongst other things
yeah because amongst other things but
like think about it it's like Italians
Puerto Ricans Catholics they get it they
get hit by the nuns so it kind of gets
screwed into you know cuz the nuns hit
you guys and the priests [ __ ] you guys
yeah but to deal with things in weird
ways we just missed that though nobody
was hitting in my school my mother and
father got hit a lot by that by the you
were hitting in school uh right I was
more hitting the priests by the time I
got school priests and nuns couldn't do
anything I definitely got a little I got
stuff screwed in by father Bill a couple
of late nights after church but that's
just what it is yeah on that's why I
have sexual fetishes but I didn't get
hit the rest you got caressed by piss
yeah my vice-principal try the molest me
once
really yeah huh we're also alike
he was he would he would prey on like
troubled children mhm so like when I was
a kid like I'll get some fights or like
tell potential teacher to suck my penis
sure or lean pee my clean pee yeah I
would have burned my teacher untouched
untouched untouched clean pee but I was
just like hey like you know like [ __ ]
you throw a couple garbage cancer some
windows so he works with the troubled
kids and he was like man this guy
really nice gave long hugs yeah it was
really nice yeah sounds like you missed
a few hugs you know he hugged me yeah
one time it was kind of like a little
weird and like he like did like a very
gay breath on my neck yeah it was deep
breath you know and it was like okay
right and then he would send me letters
and then we call me Wow and then he
would call me late at night and then my
dad disciplined him my Italian dad just
goes take us through it my dad found
like he's like sees that he sent me like
ya letter he goes kind of gay isn't it
yeah and I was just like at the time I
was like nah like he's helped me out guy
goes to another school gets busted
sure for just trying to suck dick oh
yeah after I got screwed in by father
bill I would just pull my dick out all
the time and then I remember one time I
was with my dad hanging out was his
weekend and I was hanging out with this
with this friend of mine in the
neighborhood and we were sitting on his
stoop and I just started pulling my dick
out I'm laugh which is weird you know
thirteen years old and then the guy's
father the kid's father saw me pull my
dick out and chased me down with my
[ __ ] baseball bat and was i calling
me a [ __ ] running down some block on
Staten Island and I was just like shoved
the street sign up yeah yeah yeah and I
was just like and I was just like
running away like ran into my dad and
just like denied the whole thing but
like you know like I still to this day
just have an urge I always just want to
kind of just let my penis out a little
bit and I don't know what it is but
definitely happened after I took after I
took a couple of sacraments to the face
from father Bill yeah yeah yeah you're a
disturbed kid is what it is what it is
yeah you disturbed documentary on
Netflix about like all the like the
priests all the the the the the sinner
no Baltimore dude he would not say the
father would not on them and then do the
sign of the Cross in the nut and is like
like not a fire happens but your mom
being Catholic right yes your Catholic
as well no Greek Orthodox all right I'm
gonna get to you later okay we got like
we got like no pedophilia yeah yeah yeah
we're clean what clear yeah but you guys
like we do other stuff guys are like big
orgy people though right we do a lot of
weird stuff yeah put a lot of stuff in
our butts that's why I invented anal
guys invented anal
yeah your mom when she sees your content
now mm-hmm how did she react she gets
you know upset by some of the things
that I say but it's kind of one of those
things where it's like look yeah it's
upsetting to hear some of this stuff but
you know I'm also the kids moving
tickets cousin Atlanta tickets and it's
like it's a hey do you want your rent
pay it's the one thing it's like I take
care of my whole family or in like you
know I got my [ __ ] in order so it's like
what you know I think if I was doing
what I was doing and also doing drugs
and also not doing well financially and
not you know make and my kid wasn't
clean like that would be a problem but
it's like you know he says a couple of
things that are wild comedic Lee and she
gets upset by it but ultimately she's
like I can't you know I had my doctorate
degree I have like I've done things that
a mom likes I realize that
accomplishments who cares it's like
that's all your ego being like oh do do
so I do that it's like shut up
you're just shut up and you have a
friend from Park Slope which is you have
a friend from Park Slope
mungus it's you yeah home in Westchester
now so it's like that's yeah I have I
have one friend in Battery Park and I'm
clinging to him that's what we lost
touch and I'm not really happy about
used to live there I used to live there
25 years I knew because you're short
applause your sweaters a little nicer
than his I know the money flow okay yeah
that's got a zipper on it you know this
is from the Banana Republic oh yeah when
I came here I was like I [ __ ] it was
like I don't know if I'm gonna get you
guys this is like a little beneath me
yeah it's crazy a very Queens situation
I know I know he soon as we come in the
door yeah this is out of character
stereo he goes I've never been here yeah
like yeah yeah sorry
yeah yeah yeah no he's got that vibe
about yeah you're a real punchable face
actually hasn't been hit more in its
life yeah shots Boosh
I like that yeah I'm bougie shed from
the same cloth you can deal with it like
you guys [ __ ] to Stefano and it's
time to go we're [ __ ] Union not gonna
work guys
look you can't [ __ ] it you need a roof
we got your [ __ ] roof who would go
broke first of you to me out of us like
what do you mean like like who's a more
frivolous everything we do we do
together I think like thumb and Louise
we just hold hands and jump off jump off
yeah guys drive you hit that car do you
guys give each other financial advice um
not really not really not real has to be
my basically my financial advisor yes I
don't know if I don't talk to the kid
he's gonna be he's gonna be on the
street yeah yeah I love spending money
take it you don't take it with you and
then in the next world in the next you
also need some to last you know which
was my next question well yeah well that
changes things are you worried about
your kids seeing your content at some
point I mean I guess the short answer is
yes but also it's like I can talk to
I'll just have a conversation with my
kid about what's going on so just an
example how you can explain to your kid
what a transgender X Eskimo is I'm gonna
say that's because that was hard for me
to understand I'm gonna say that's what
daddy was identifying that day yeah and
and I'll show you and I'll draw an
Eskimo in an igloo and we'll draw you
know both genitals and and I'll show
that I can tuck one back behind the
other one and then I'm a transgender
Eskimo no see this is my friend Jana
show her where transgender isn't okay
yeah and Gotha yeah that her grandmother
will come out and say stop my ashtray
yes yeah that's what she wanted to do
she wanted she said your friend is
Maurice I said yes because I my ashtray
his name is mama water it's a sign -
trade that I was trying to give away I
had to have it it I gave it to him I
have a wild other part of my family
oh you're [ __ ] family's crazy I wasn't
I was gonna throw the ashtray away he
said no I'll give it to her and then she
took issues like this it nice
she liked it then she said wait a second
okay he's fine it so I took a sharpie
and I signed the ashtray so somewhere
you sign it on the bottom of it all cuz
she's she's pretty that's going on the
wall that's never to be that's Marie so
signature we putting that on the wall
you do you want to know what I took the
most from your video
yeah is that you can actually shoot a
jump shot like all the other stuff was
like yeah oh this is funny
I'm like yeah I'm like yo it's good for
we're watching we're watching and we're
watching one of the more ease of videos
and he goes kind of all got the second I
had a little tiny game not as good this
kid was actually the all-time leader in
st. Joe's history scoring yeah its
division three but yeah I don't [ __ ]
that basketball was my whole life
that's like white Division one white
division white division one yeah yeah if
you're the leading scorer of a Division
three college then your white d1 a
professional oh my god while my dad used
to my dad you still like my regimen was
a thousand jump shots a day every day my
dad was like in between jobs are doing
something illegal when I was a teenager
so we would go to farmers oval Park Fair
Park they but they callin farmers oval
in Ridgewood and we would take a
thousand jump shots a day almost every
day or five days a week at least and
then we would do it was all basically
drills and then the last 200 shots I
swear to god he had a broom that he
wrote Leroy on to mimic a 7-foot guy
that he assumes was black with the name
Leroy and he would hold that up and I
would shoot jump shots over the broom to
mimic high-arcing jumpers over big men
and then I started and then the shot got
so good that I was able to just kind of
hit threes or hit jump shots from
anywhere Jim Boeheim the coach of
Syracuse and was like you have a
Division one jump shot in Division three
body I was at the Eastern Invitational
they only invite 150 high school kids I
was one of the kids that got invited
because that's why your acclimate
they're so funny they've got your number
on your jerseys yeah whatever invitation
you yeah Leroy which is also a way they
were my stick which is also a way they
order coffees in Ridgewood we said this
on the podcast instead of saying kind of
get my coffee black I say can I get my
coffee Leroy
[Laughter]
don't realize is is pretty crazy now now
when you get in the lifts you have to
give the person your pronouns have you
seen that no what do you mean so it's
like if you get into a lift it's so the
lift driver can you know address you
address you as the right pronoun so it's
like you know sir ma'am yeah other but
you see this is why Trump this is why
Trump I think is gonna win again in a
landslide because like there's 1% of the
population cares about the pronouns yeah
and yeah the Democrats on there be like
we support the pronouns like [ __ ] okay
nobody supports the pronouns yeah the
real actual 99% of working class people
love whatever you want to be on the work
whatever you want to be transgender I
[ __ ] love everybody I don't care what
your problem who cares about the pronoun
I'll call you [ __ ] Elmo or any Eskimo
I want meet you with kindness and
respect because you're a human being but
the pronouns it's like if that's what
you're putting your campaign on it's
like good luck Elizabeth Warren and
whoever yeah people care about policy
and money can you care about like unless
Andrew yang gets it if Angie ain't get
so he might get my boat kids a [ __ ]
good Chinese kid and I like his policy
you getting twelve twelve twelve kids of
national income yeah I like yang NotI to
just goes up not giving a [ __ ] I like it
he's actually sick like talking about
things where you going like he's got a
lot of good point like he's actually
talking about the future realist yeah
and he says remember like guys there's
no more jobs and he says he's actually
their underwear making this a job now
there's he no job and he's as American
as you can be because he was made in
China so it's just perfect just so you
know we're keeping all God that's a good
one that's yeah that's a good one
have you ever noticed when you go to
like they're good people they're great
yeah not too hot sort of like Woodbury
comments like one of those places yeah
those outlet stores no agent people are
rich [ __ ] hell yeah well they just walk
around with the mask on and
100 bags from Shenzhen money dude where
the bubble aliens are taking over the
world which is yeah rushing there's a
building our friend lives in the Eugene
it's like down the block from Madison
Square Garden and it's like this
beautiful luxury high-rise building and
everyone everyone agent yeah enriched it
absolutely Wow I'm like it this kids 23
years old who I really believe the
Chinese government is like is
subsidizing and like giving their
citizens who move here money to just buy
apartments cuz there's so many vacant
apartments that are just sitting at the
Chinese own from Beijing it's just a
thing these are crushing him they're
crushing it every time I'm there I might
yo they don't they like they don't speak
the language mm-hmm
but their richest [ __ ] oh my how are you
doing this yeah no I know what they
don't learn the language because they
don't feel like they need to learn
English yeah like you guys need to learn
Chinese the great Roy Wood jr. a great
friend of mine who are children hang out
a lot great comedian his child goes to
school great his child goes through
school where they're teaching them
Chinese and I'm like that's smart yeah
boys sons gonna know Chinese and I want
my daughter to know the fact that we
that's that's another [ __ ]
systematical [ __ ] systemic problem
with America is that we just think
English is fine yeah we just think
English and not using the metric system
is fine and then every crazy ya ever get
that every European I ever meet is like
fluent in English sure well okay here's
the thing here's the only the only
unless it's like [ __ ] it only
defense I'll say it's not not a defense
but I think the reason is and I is
because you can go you know 3,000 miles
and only hearing English I mean these 50
states are tall English in Europe you go
a hundred miles and it's a new language
yeah yes the only issue I think it it
says Romania spoke was still speaking
Dutch we would know Dutch you know what
I mean if Florida was speaking Spanish
we would know Spanish or we would have a
more command of it but it's like
wherever we go is everyone speaking
English yeah so it's also like listen
guy we won the war so you speak the
language again we [ __ ] one guy okay
right it's like listen the hurts I know
France
I know France you know you want to sit
here and think you got to speak French
it's like guy Paris is just an extension
in New York City okay so why don't you
relax yeah and make me a croissant buck
bass I
I think everyone should learn English
but everyone should [ __ ] French yeah
yeah no no this is a sex language with
some like some rasping us in your voice
yeah good morning do you like this do
you like this it's kind of bland yeah
but like French's I love talking during
sex oh yeah that's what I'm saying I
wish I spoke French you guys like to
suck on your lobes
oh yes sucking a girl's ear lobe oh man
sex I'll bite it I don't buy let you
skip a little suck I'm into sucking I
like to suck lower lips to lick the
teeth
I love sucking don't know why I'm doing
this to him massaging a nipple looking
at I like to lick the bottom row teeth
and stock the bottom lip and suck on
your earlobe a little bit I like to
smell my dried saliva honor your lobe is
that wild you smell it I just turns me
on
but I'm your own breath but I'm gonna be
honest with you and I think I said this
the last time we hung out in Yanis knows
this the horniest I am throughout the
day ever is when I'm talking to smart
guys right yeah so I'm horny when I'm
talking up in great conversation with
men like I'm you're definitely a gay guy
I'm not a hundred percent straight I'll
tell you that yeah I'll tell you this
you haven't figured it out I haven't
figured out I don't want to wait for his
dad to die I don't want to have sex with
a guy I'm not into them sex with that
but I like to talk to guys and and and
and I don't mind a hairy woman so I'll
say that a woman who has a deck or broom
named Lera it's what it is I can stick
it all up my ass honey go get Leroy yeah
before we wrap up here we do have
questions that we ask and so at the end
of all these episodes are you gay all
right so the first the first question
the sheets that are currently on your
bed okay how long they've been there my
funny you ask that
just last night my daughter wet the bed
for the third time in a row so I just
had to change my sheets so the sheets
are curling on my bed are brand spanking
new with next to no toddler urine stains
on them so she's pissing all over you
she's I keep giving her apple juice at
night can't do that what an idiot yeah
so no no I I did it I did unless she's
just I know she's kids just go through
faith swear they wet the bed so so
she'll pissed she pissed
are you in like that that area where
it's like it's my kid like the same as
other kids I'm in that area where is she
learning that the right rate yeah yeah
well the thing is with now it's at the
area where you really like I have to you
know like read to her every night and
talk and now I'm at the thing where it's
like I'm gonna start I have to have
conversation with my daughter sounds
powerful that push the ball forward it
can't just be like eat your food it's
like you have to now start to be like do
you understand why you need to eat
understand why this like you know why
you need to say things you know like
take certain types of charts ain't date
certain types of kids you know like what
tax brackets are and which ones don't or
in the lower ones and which ones in the
higher one right neighborhoods they live
yeah stuff like that a tax exemption on
your health exactly it's like it's like
you got to start to get under my now
like you're half half white half Puerto
Rican strata so what we're gonna do is
we're going to be a Puerto Rican on
college interviews and white on job
interviews it's just what is we got
diversity we got to get in and then we
get whites get two jobs I'm guilty I'm
guilty yeah what about your she's my
she's probably like shame to say I think
three weeks oh wow he doesn't have a
hundred percent clean out most of the
time dying around me so I've been busy I
got friends dying I got dad's dying I
don't got time to change my sheets yeah
this close friends have venereal
diseases and I just bought a house I got
no money can I work for the basement of
yours yeah I need money any ads you sell
on this can we have a percentage of the
honest anybody I got nobody I just
bought house for my wife and her dad and
kicking it down so funny that spectrum
is so wild though cuz it's like yeah you
know my dad just passed away like you're
talking to someone it's like damn dude
I'm really sorry to hear that so yeah
but I just bought a house yeah so
there's that well you know it's wild
it's actually just to get serious for a
second being a comedian is a strange
thing
professionally because like when you're
going through emotional stuff and then
your job is to go cheer people up yeah
it's you have to like put a wall up that
can only stay up with the help of drugs
alcohol or some sort of ice all right
that's what I've learned and if you
don't have one of those which I don't
cuz I just try to be healthy and I tried
you just you're gonna crash bad thing
you're gonna like have you got there
yeah yeah I had to cancel the whole
weekend was embarrassed I got carried
out in a stretcher being carried out on
a stretcher when nothing's wrong with
you is one of the funniest it's happened
to me multiple you know you know is wild
you know this is how connected we are
I'm in Vegas doing shows he's in
Providence Rhode Island doing shows I
get a call from the Providence Rhode
Island comedy club from the owners of
that club call me because he passed out
on stage I'm like what about his wife
they're like we just figured we could
get to you quicker guys emergency
contact like we he put down to watch you
and his actual wife so we called this
one first yeah yeah yeah it was just
like the floodgates just gate just came
down and I couldn't no I couldn't do
comedy like I just my body was just
crashed my mind I was just like a
mentally exhausted cuz like if you're
going through [ __ ] you and you work a
regular job
you just sit at your cubicle and you
just yeah you zone out and do whatever
but if you're like hey guys yeah you
know it's like you can only do that
before you got it like blowing brains
out well I know I was in a psych ward
for four days all right I saw I saw that
cocktail pills you had to put in your
face before 15 depakote shoot if I don't
take those everyone's yeah I'm ready for
my close-up mr. deville just let me hold
on yeah dude
I really do say though everyone should
spend some time in a mental institution
yeah you were social worker out one that
was yeah I was a social worker that had
to take clients - yeah psych wards yeah
the worst is when you go there and then
you can't go anywhere you look in prison
yeah I could go there like nah what
happened you're here what do you I had a
nervous breakdown
yes like when Dad were you here did you
see it house yeah yeah in real time so
what happened can you be so what was
happening with me was is that out I was
drinking a lot and I was also this yeah
riding the white horse yeah yeah yeah
yeah so shout out to the white horse
great great great person come on the
ship ruined my life
yeah so I stopped doing that
corruptly oh but we're just like because
we would be I had a beer fridge next to
my computer yeah so like random nothing
feels like snowing or something or like
it
a second I like craft beer so I would
have like these you know 16-ounce cans
and black art let's just start drinking
during the day and then at one point I
was like I just had accident I was like
yo how I was like I feel like I've been
drinking a lot like I've been drinking
like every Friday Saturday and sometimes
Thursday yeah like every real time right
in my line not just a few beers like I'm
dran beers yeah yeah so I'm saying that
songs like I feel like I've been
drinking a lot is like yeah dude I drink
a lot too I was like how often do you
think you drink and then he was like I
don't know like four or five times a
week
I was like what sounds like I was like
so like a Wednesday when you're watching
the Yankees like how many beers do you
have he's like I don't know like six
seven like that's a lot yeah yeah that's
too much I'm like that's not like one
beer or anything I got drunk pretty much
everyday so we uh we agreed that we were
just going to stop drinking for 30 days
and then he got eight days in had a
[ __ ] Tony had a heart attack then had
a mental breakdown and then he was so
what happened what actions over the
symptom so I quit all the stuff okay and
all the stuff that I was suppressing
with my alcohol and drug use I was like
oh man that's not there and I just
started having these [ __ ] panic
attacks and we're like I felt like I was
having a heart attack my hands would
start tingling I feel like I was gonna
lose consciousness I couldn't shower I
couldn't do it I was afraid of
everything yeah and yeah and we were
doing a show and I just started crying
in the middle of it right I was talking
to him I said looking at him and across
the thing and he's on his phone and he's
like looking at something and he I think
you're like texting your mom at the time
and then I can see that he's starting to
lose it and I'm just and then I just
like hit pause and the thing I was like
yeah what's going on he goes I can't and
I was like oh my god and then that day
ended with me standing on the sidewalk
and Danny standing in the street and
like basically yelling like yo I can't
live like this and like trying and the
end of it he's just like put on some
performance those like construction
workers like a guy somebody Felix I
literally cried into this carpet yeah
like I wasn't this apartment though no
no the other apartment yep so then I was
like yo like and then everyone starts
telling you like yo you're fine right
there's nothing wrong with nothing wrong
with you and I'm like yo but there's
something wrong with me because so what
happened was this is a very funny story
I was think about killing myself which
Hilaire hilarious and I was like yeah
I'm either gonna jump off this Terrace
or I'm gonna go to Lennox Hill Hospital
and see if they could chain me to a
radiator for a couple days right so I so
I did I chose the yeah
so I get there and I'm like yo listen
and I made the mistake when they ask you
do you have you had thoughts about
killing yourself yeah and I said yeah no
but it was a good thing yes yeah and
then they were like alright like they
just like call a couple people like
trick to you like brought you through
another room so like you can't run out
so they were like alright so give us all
of your [ __ ] and I was like all my [ __ ]
and I was just like yeah they were like
we need your shoelaces you have any
shorts with the ties in it they took all
my [ __ ] and then they left me in a room
with a paranoid schizophrenic for four
days
oh boy yeah and you wanted to kill
yourself yeah yeah yeah and then a skunk
I made the wrong choice he would yell in
the middle of the night and saying I was
stealing his things so I didn't sleep
for four days so what happened though
was is that they set up like a good
Network for me I got out I've been in
therapy since I've been clean and I just
learned coping mechanisms the way to
deal with my [ __ ] yeah is I had a lot of
[ __ ] that I didn't address yeah and I
had to address it with especially with
the people that I didn't address it with
yeah and that [ __ ] was humbling his [ __ ]
hell yeah
just being like hey remember that whole
period where I was just a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
yeah about that this is why yeah yeah
but like having the physical symptoms
like I went to a hospital on a stretcher
and I was like I'm dying and they were
like dude here's some like ativan shut
the [ __ ] up okay yeah you know right
that's what drugs that's what yeah they
usually a lot of people would do that to
drown that out you know because it's
easier yeah I had to stop all that [ __ ]
cuz I was losing my [ __ ] they're
gonna hurt yourself out there tell
people yeah tell someone help yeah yeah
there's no shame in getting help no
that's the hardest thing was that's that
like a challenge runner me I couldn't
leave there is like that Italian bravado
where it's like just bury it
my father like buried [ __ ] for years and
now he's in therapy and he's like the
nicest guy ever
my dad didn't tell me you love me until
he's like $27 I was like 27 years old
yeah yeah you know well he doesn't love
you that's what I'm saying he just says
it now what can you do you know my
doctors told him the
you gotta start saying or else you lose
your kiddies again I'll say it oh yeah
yeah yeah he's contractually obligated
yeah it's like yeah if he wants to get
some [ __ ] baby why'd you go like all
right I want this amount of money and 14
I love yous yeah I want five hide hugs
yeah well he's got a few to make up he's
the nerves running out he's 12 let's
look at the sign and in my head it's
making me laugh I keep going
Santa God oh all right so this next
question okay this next question is so
long the line that's very serious like
that if you guys are right with
answering it name five kid rock songs um
Bob with the BA okay you got one Diggy
dang that's what the nookie I did it all
for the no escape [ __ ]
no one's been able to do this I don't
know I don't know any kid rock Kid Rock
USA or is that his bar I don't know yeah
I don't know any Kid Rock can we name
like another guy like Detroit isn't he
from Detroit he probably definitely has
a song named Detroit some accountant
he's got that one Bob with the bottom
bang debate that's good that's the only
song same one that we know it's our
another one I know there's a couple yeah
call me kid Rock they call me kid writes
that same song I want to be a cowboy
baby I want to be a cowboy baby yeah I
got a one eat the booty like groceries
yeah I was so taken taken back when I
found out who he was black for some
really taken back because cuz yeah talk
about it when you're a kid when you're a
kid do you remember when you were a kid
you honestly didn't really know what
like artists look like yeah you just
heard their music yeah and I was like I
was like yeah I listened to so much rap
music and then I saw a picture holding
the Blowfish I was just like
that's a black man I thought the Beastie
Boys were black when I was a kid so yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right next question
here we have Tim buddy one day I hope
gets that kid Rock oh yeah yeah uh
what's something you have to do every
day like I'm not like take a [ __ ] or
piss or the jerk-off now I gotta speak
to Chrissy every day once a day makes me
happy that's the Chrissy every day I got
a text with Chrissy at least once a day
okay yeah I so that well that's his
answer I'm so I'm involved in that one
so I guess that that also counts it's my
one but me something I got to do every
single day he's still googling James
Harden without a shirt on I know not
Jake Tom Hardy Tom Hardy I google Tom
Hardy without a shirt on back in a day
I'm guilty I'm back in the day I'm
something I have to do every single day
um antibiotics you don't have to do that
I don't do that in my fort I mean my
daughter I speak to my daughter every
day or see her but that's like Julie
else am I the situation yelled up by her
mom the situation so you guys are on
good terms
yeah oh I got to take my omega-3 fish
oil pills every day okay yeah yeah for
good heart health and brain health and
burp that [ __ ] up both that us yeah
the next question is what animal best
describes you or not I gonna have sex we
know we're gonna go left left to right
stage left or right rate yourself one to
ten four I need that's elaborate yeah
yeah no rookie scores oh no I can't go
for no you gotta go for if you'd like
[ __ ] yeah that's or I'm stupid I'm
really stupid I can't do math I have to
push the bill over to my girlfriend my
wife see I'm stupid she's my wife
I got a push to her so she can do tips I
fix that part to keep you stupid I'm
[ __ ] stupid yeah some before and I'm
like an almost handsome kid yeah I'm
like I look like John Stamos if John
Stamos had something bad with him look
like a like a John Stamos his brother
who got the other genes yeah you look
like John Stamos his business manager
yes who's also got some Stamos I look
like John stammers ugh
brother I'm gonna bump that up to six
yeah because just cuz it Stamos yeah
[ __ ] six thank you I mean come on you
[ __ ] sex rocket I'm gonna say I'm
gonna give myself a 7.5 because my
favorite band is the 1975 and then I
love that band and I'm the only straight
guy at the concerts and so that I would
say I'm only gonna get myself a 7.5
today at that because I feel like I'm
coming into the best version of myself
that cart all this is gay yeah because I
feel like I'm staying in the present now
as much as possible reminding myself to
stay in the present I've accepted things
as they are not as I wish they were
which is the thing that George
Washington was famous for doing when he
was a great leader cuz he didn't you
know he's just accept them as they are
now you're wishing you spent a lot of
energy wishing you got to do it as they
are now if you ever have enjoyed the
Schultz's I guess you ask him when he
rates himself he's gonna go 20 baby yes
said 1 to 10 I must say 20 it's what it
is I tried to give you the future and
you didn't want it yeah what do you
think you go up you to go down all right
from now from from now from today I
think that I'm I think that I'm trying
to go up I would say this I'm happy at
if I never got any higher then a 7.5 I'd
be very happy with that be perfectly
comfortable I'm perfectly comfortable
just being I'm not content comfortable
I'm comfortable with it right cause I
feel like being a 7.5 is good enough for
to give my daughter a good life I just
think about my kid now do chlamydia save
your [ __ ] life
yeah even before that Sam Adams with
Maria there's always a build-up there's
always a build-up of stuff yeah helps
you change sure mine was a nervous
breakdown
yours was chlamydia yes maybe yeah maybe
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I was
feeling this way before that I think
chlamydia just like you know solidified
it was the bacteria on top it was a drip
on top have a low chlamydia chowder and
you're good to go
exactly what game show do you think you
guys would be best on are the newlyweds
yeah 90-day fiance
[ __ ] it's terrible yeah yeah
is it really 90 days and then you marry
them do you have to marry them or what's
the deal I don't know we're going on it
no I actually what games I mean jeopardy
no maybe you know what I would say wheel
of fortune because we're a couple of
kids that spin the wheel yeah we should
win the wheel and that's how I got
chlamydia I'm spinning the wheel good
it's spinning the wheel watch it watch
it
yeah yeah he spins wheel with everything
wait like whatever comes out of his
mouth it's a wheel spin a wheel space is
it gonna be true is it gonna be a lie I
don't know it's all I could go in a
podcast right after this and just give
completely different me yeah oh yeah
that's the best part about being a
sociopath and a sociopath is that we can
just be people that we just made up that
day well that's like people get all bent
out of shape like even with stand-up or
stuff like is that what you're saying
true who cares what is you just for an
hour just be present in the moment and
enjoy the entertainment yeah just enjoy
it
yeah that's why it's like listen have
fun just stop caring about everything
yeah take a little time off take a
little time for you being a little tight
booty boy yeah what's your least
favorite feature about yourself my eyes
are too close together yeah he's got two
eyes are too close I like a cyclops I
mean oh my yeah you want to see him
without the glasses cuz these frame them
and separate them on let's see it yeah
he's he's human ayahuasca eyes open my
nickname is one eye guy yes his name is
Yanni ayahuasca cuz he's got a third eye
yeah that's and I got no but yeah it's
got no but my my nipples I have a nipple
nipple I have an off-center nipple one
of my nipples looks like an anteater
that's why we're comes out you comes out
I wear sweaters like that the word you
know he's hiding in fact have you have
you ever pinch your nipples before a
photo no I never got to do that I do
that sometimes because I don't have soft
nips and pigs
yeah I got I got salami like kind of
just like pinkish off-centered nipples
that by far as my my chesticles in
general are the worst part about me what
would you do like shirtless modeling
though I don't think I can physically
like no one would want you yeah yeah
it's always it's always like it's the
casting director
describe me perfectly once he said you
have leading-man face best friend bond
[Laughter]
that's what I'm saying that's what makes
you so funny is like you also you had a
division-one jump shot in a division
body it's just this this I have these
gifts that just kind of aren't right
there cuz you're Chrissy breaks even cuz
if I was a leading man face to the
leading man bonny and division one jump
shot would be I wouldn't be funny I
would have a career in something else
that's an air think you know it's like
how many comedians are just like
complete smoke shows like dudes nah not
many not many you got to have something
off or else you're not gonna be funny
yeah they're just gonna be a smoke show
dude then you'll just be an actor yeah
yeah yeah absolutely yeah all right last
question yeah are you happy today I'm
very happy today yeah this was a lot of
fun this is a real question like we
actually mean this right yeah today I'm
today I'm happy just bought a house
yesterday congratulations yeah very cool
one day I will what's the edge of all
winning you guys make me wait you guys
come over now yeah yeah it's got a nice
look I saw you said it what's the shoe
offshore I'm going shoe off shoe offs
Japanese on my house yeah yeah nobody
you have to establish that from the jump
I know you're gonna have some [ __ ]
[ __ ] shoe wearing freaks especially
if I went there people walking in just
put in [ __ ] Mouse Aki's on do you
have a mudroom I don't know what we got
yet we could make you have a room for me
yep yeah I got it removed for the pace
yeah we're gonna [ __ ] 2020 we're
gonna turn my house into a studio that's
what it is we're gonna do my bestie for
your bestie um you're happy as well I'm
happy yeah I'm had I tell a cart cart oh
no I'm happy I'm happy because I feel
like I was I was I had like a scare a
real scare and it's on the other side
now so I feel like I was just like given
some clarity and with really not that
much not that many scars and I just feel
extremely lucky and it's a small dig
it's small but it's like another lease
on life you got out a little lease on
life and also I'm happy because I'm just
I mean I'm in the present yeah just
trying to stay in the present and I
really don't have I'm very happy with my
present I got a daughter that I love a
career that I love I don't need to add
anything
that's awesome yeah we're just blessed I
mean look at what we're doing we're just
having this is our job we have oh yes if
you if you take a step back and try to
give yourself perspective everyday it
helps yeah it's like hey man you have to
it so everybody should do that at least
once mother had to work like 28 hours a
day yeah and that was his life
Greek kid obviously owned a diner and
like Greek people have a great way of
making more hours in three minutes
this was my job you know what I you know
what I'm happy too because I identified
like as Chris I identify just as me my
job is not a part of me my yeah you know
me being a father it's not a part of me
it's like all these things I mean I love
being a dad and but it's like I'm just
happy cuz I'm me it's like so if you
took everything away from me it's like
you know you had people in Japan for a
long time like you would have your job
for life and then they started to ask
you know democracy started to creep in
there they started to fire people like
you how it is now Japanese men were
killing themselves left and right yeah
because they identified only as their
job and then you take their job away or
it's like you know my mom worked for 30
years and then she lose her job she's
like what am I supposed to do or when
people retire it's like oh yeah with
this career you don't have that because
I'm me every single day yeah so
everything I do as a dad as a comedian
it's always me so I don't I'm not
identifying with anything but me so it's
cool you know I never thought I better
like that because I feel like I've been
on both sides where I worked jobs where
you know you you do become part of that
it's like oh you're the cashier you know
they're not who you are you are the
cashier for a lot of people do that too
like if you've never worked in the
service industry like you walk into a
place and it's like sometimes people
treat waiters or you know chefs or
whoever guesses as like oh they're Duras
chef this is their jobs so it's like not
to do to human businessperson you know I
mean so that is an interesting
perspective I'd never get chlamydia
it'll be clear has been a great sponsor
for chlamydia yeah absolutely that's a
great sponsor I always think about that
too it's like because you want to know
we don't really think about it because
like we're in the hustle and bustle like
trying to like make content and push it
out but it's really nice when like
someone will send you like a genuine
comment and she'd be like dude you're
great hell yeah like you've like saved
my life I don't lie dude I'm just some
[ __ ] fat dude from Westchester
you know what I mean so like it really
shows that like you know yeah it we we
got into this for a reason and we're
doing it the right way yeah yeah it's a
great feeling to know like you know what
I was right about something yes that's a
true currency you know that's just
that's the thing that lives on after you
is the energy you put out it goes and
other people goes into their kids and
your kids cuz all the other [ __ ] we're
all going down cuz like my goal in life
is that when I go and people come to my
funeral they go you know what that was a
good guy yeah yeah so I want that's it
that's all I want and you're not that
hard to get and I feel like people
complicate like everything in their life
like you know worrying about this and
that but it's like at the end of the day
I think that's what everyone wants when
you really ask them it's like it's not
that hard stuff yeah it's very good or
you could be a piece of [ __ ] but you
don't get back on the right track yeah
yeah before you go yeah or if your piece
of [ __ ] don't pretend like you're not a
piece of [ __ ] those are the real pieces
of [ __ ] to me you know I respect pieces
of [ __ ] yes if you if you're up front
about being a piece of [ __ ] yeah I don't
like the people who pretend like they're
not and then they are that's a real
piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah the other ones I
just kind of respect I'm going like you
know what I really true I respect you
know you're an [ __ ] and you you say
you're an [ __ ] and you're upfront
about it and I respect that yeah I don't
like when you're pretending this is
something that it's not yeah cuz that's
what that's what cowards do
that's what cowards do yeah be who you
are out front [ __ ] me [ __ ] me you know
yeah yeah not the [ __ ] officer deal
yeah yeah a blinder at Kristy comedy
yeah yeah make sure also guys it was
fantastic I have them on yes where can
we find like I don't want to get slapped
yeah you know uh yes italiancakes a
discipline yo yeah what do you guys got
going we leave he's gonna [ __ ] me you
can check out all my dates chris d
comedy calm i got what is that no good
christy comedy I got a bunch of stand-up
discipline yeah I don't know when this
episode's coming out but but I'm in
Denver Atlantic City
[ __ ] Portland all these all these put
Newark New Jersey your work New Jersey
it is theater geek so I need two tickets
to come Christie
comedy calm Yanis Papas comedy calm New
York City Gotham comedy club February
21st and 2nd and then uncle Vinny's in
Point Pleasant New Jersey to file a
weekend February 28th 29th listen to a
podcast history hyenas and check out our
website for that history hyenas comm we
got a bunch of fun stuff up there and we
got patreon.com slash Bay Ridge Boys but
want to be part of the matriarchy and
get your pseudo penis wet yeah and also
check out Eckhart Tolle he'll help you
find your third eye hello people get
your third eye and you can look like you
on it and get tested I think you do have
chlamydia then get ready for a new life
don't worry yes it's a new beginning
people after listening to this episode
people gonna get chlamydia and be like
thank God yeah I needed this yeah yeah
tweet you tweet your results hashtag
Chrissy chlamydia Hey there will be
comments in the YouTube like you know
like I never really thought about it but
like Chris really opened my eyes about
chlamydia and I'm actually gonna take
his advice and yeah people go too far
and they go I want to be open I have
full-blown AIDS and I've had it for
years the comments in the episode are
gonna go with like that too like you
guys were talking about the Queen again
guys gone like I thought this was a
[ __ ] home improvement podcast real a
real range of comments that runs the
gamut
all right cool guys thank you for coming
on it was a lot of fun thanks we'll see
you guys next time
[Music]